you know movies can be adapted from many
sources books plays and songs yeah why
stop there you could do text messages
tick tock dances recipes
recipes oh yeah
can you imagine the depth and the
lightness in a screenplay about a
waldorf salad i mean have you ever tried
to make one can can you imagine how you
would find the through line sean how
would you adapt that sweet yet crunchy
nuance of the relationship between the
grape and the walnut
well the best writers do know how to do
that yes they do oh yes they do shall we
announce the nominees yes it seems like
we've set the table for the talent
here
are the nominees for adapted screenplay
coda screenplay by sean hayden based on
the original motion picture la famine
bellier
written by victoria bedos stannis last
corey de malberg eric lardigo and thomas
[Music]
drive my car screenplayed by ryusuke
hamaguchi takamasa oe based on the story
by haruki murakami
dune screenplayed by john spates and
denis villeneux and eric roth based on
the novel by frank herbert
the lost daughter written by maggie
gyllenhaal based on the novel by elena
ferrante
the power of the dog written by jane
campion based on the book by thomas
savage
all right and the oscar goes to
sean hader
this is the first oscar and nomination
for sean hader
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god
i'm so glad i dressed as a disco ball
um
oh my god
this um
this was an independent film and it was
incredibly hard to get made so i want to
thank my team doug i want to thank
my producers all of you for believing in
me and how i wanted to make this movie i
want to thank sundance for starting this
journey
i
i want to thank
apple for being amazing partners on this
ride
writing and making this movie was truly
life-changing as an artist and as a
human being i want to thank all of my
collaborators in the deaf community and
the coda community for being my teachers
and alexandria for bringing my words to
life in this beautiful cinematic
language i want to thank my entire crew
i want to name you all paul gero marius
nick um dave joe
oh my god diane
all of you um my incredible cast
um amelia marley
troy daniel
ohenia ferdia amy you guys are
incredible you're my family and i want
to thank my real life family my mom and
dad are here somewhere up there
my sister tara
you guys are artists you made me an
artist you made me make things my
husband david i couldn't do this without
you
it's so hard to be a director and a mom
and you make it possible
and my kids
nico and milo i love you guys so much i
love you forever
[Applause]
you